[Música]
2022 el año más devastador jamás
registrado en materia de incendios
ese verano gironda se consume toma
consciencia
el azote climático ya no perdona las
zonas templadas
Cómo se prepara Francia para esta nueva
temporada de riesgo que elecciones se
aprendieron el verano pasado
en el suroeste de Francia la temporada
de buen tiempo está a punto de empezar
aquí se alza la duna de arena más alta
de Europa la duna de pilat A sus pies se
ve un paisaje asolado por la catástrofe
del año pasado
en el bosque no hay Caminantes A pocas
semanas del anuncio de su apertura
muchos de los campamentos aún no se han
reconstruido
Pero hay uno que renació de las cenizas
todo esto se quemó entonces realmente
tuvimos que reconstruir todo
dirige el campamento
Además estoy aquí puedo vigilar
después de meses de trabajo sin descanso
se cumplió el objetivo el campamento
está listo para recibir a Los visitantes
cuando inicia la temporada
volvimos a hacer los caminos rehicimos
las zonas de acampada Aunque todavía nos
queda trabajo por hacer
el campamento se volvió famoso por una
película francesa muy popular pero ahora
también es conocido por la catástrofe
del año pasado
durante el incendio se quemó todo el
campamento creo que nadie se lo habría
imaginado todo se esfumó no quedó ningún
recuerdo ninguna foto Nada
[Música]
Pero bueno esos son solo cosas
materiales
tu luz
está en su casa claro que pasa gatito es
como nuestra mascota no pudimos sacarlo
antes de que todo se incendiara cruzó
todo el bosque y lo encontró una
asociación estuvo en cuidados intensivos
durante 10 días
poco a poco regresan Los visitantes
habituales esta pareja viene desde hace
25 años
a vacacionar en la duna de pilat
Ah mi hermosa luna de Pilar Verdad que
es hermosa
Ahora les cuesta trabajo reconocer la
naturaleza que tanto amaban la impresión
que tuvimos al llegar esta mañana Es que
uno nota de inmediato que faltan árboles
pinos
porque de hecho aquí lo bonito son los
pinos Cuando llegamos pensamos Sí ya no
hay árboles no sabemos si estamos
totalmente a salvo de que vuelva a pasar
yo no estoy segura
todos temen que vuelva a ocurrir otra
catástrofe para evitarlo la región de
gironda está en alerta Empezando por los
bomberos siempre en primera línea
el fuego llegó hasta aquí con mucha
fuerza por ambos lados quedamos
atrapados en el medio estábamos con unos
jóvenes de la protección civil a los que
tuvimos que tranquilizarme
[Música]
ante el peligro creciente los Soldados
del fuego se han tenido que adaptar
ahora salen todos los días a entrenarse
en el bosque
una explicación
también aprovechan la ocasión para poner
a prueba los vehículos O al menos lo que
queda de ellos después de los estragos
del verano pasado
y se puede ver la intensidad del fuego
en esta caja se ve que todo el Metal se
derritió Durante los peores años
perdíamos un camión pero tres es muy
raro hasta ahora nunca había visto algo
así la reparación de los vehículos que
se pueden recuperar es una carrera
contrarreloj
reparamos durante todo el invierno sin
parar seguimos reparando todo el tiempo
para tener la mayor cantidad de camiones
disponibles para este verano pero no
estarán todos listos
para comprar nuevos camiones y otros
equipamientos el estado ha prometido 36
millones de euros a los bomberos del
suroeste también se han asignado
recursos adicionales para la prevención
una victoria para el alcalde de vigalls
que lo venía pidiendo hace tiempo
Este es el único bosque de Francia donde
las reglas se remontan a la Edad Media
la asociación de defensa contra los
incendios forestales en aquitania la
agrupación reúnen particular a los
propietarios forestales que poseen el
95% de las landas de gascuña sus
miembros ahora se encargan Oficialmente
de los patrullajes
vamos a estar en el bosque para
explicarle a la gente que pasea por ahí
los días que no tienen nada que hacer
porque el bosque va a estar cerrado
Durante los días de alto riesgo y
también para decirle a los que tienen
ideas malintencionadas que ya no podrán
estar tan tranquilos como antes habíamos
perdido un poco la mentalidad de
prevención por el riesgo de incendio
forestal en la región y lo que pasó el
año pasado creo que sirvió de detonante
para toda Francia en términos de cambio
climático pero para nuestra región
significó darnos cuenta de que las cosas
ya no son como antes el calentamiento
global ha cambiado las reglas del juego
en todo el país en el sur de Francia los
bomberos del departamento de barce
enfrentan a la escasez de agua
el río al lado de mi casa hace un año y
medio que no tiene agua normalmente
durante la primavera y el otoño siempre
tiene agua
nuevo reto para estos bomberos poder
llenar sus vehículos Search analiza la
disponibilidad de los recursos de agua
voy a llevarnos por la carretera para ir
hasta aquí es una fuente natural de agua
para la extracción
antes del verano algunos puntos de
abastecimiento ya estaban secos
encontrar recursos para alimentar las
cisternas es cada vez más difícil
se nota que el nivel ha bajado mucho
Search Es evidente creo que no hay
suficiente agua para la extracción
Esta es una fuente natural de agua
alimentada por las aguas de la lluvia
que no han caído durante las últimas
semanas si sacamos agua de esta fuente
extraeremos también tierra barro quizás
algunas ramas Y eso va a dañar las
bombas de nuestros camiones Entonces no
vamos a poder utilizarla
cuando una fuente de agua no se puede
usar los bomberos deben ir más lejos y
recorrer más kilómetros para abastecerse
[Aplausos]
eso causa un retraso en el tránsito y la
carga de los vehículos Entonces se
alargan los plazos de intervención es un
tiempo valioso que no estamos dedicando
a la lucha
para compensar la falta de recursos
naturales cada vez más escasos se han
establecido depósitos como este en
varias zonas del departamento
la cisterna está llena 30 metros
cuadrados de agua disponible para los
bomberos en la lucha
no alcanza podemos comprobar que el
volumen no es suficiente al compararlo
con una fuente natural de agua Aquí
tenemos 30 metros cuadrados eso permite
abastecer varias máquinas pero en un
espacio tiempo bastante limitado también
hay otra posibilidad es lo que ha hecho
el estado reforzar los recursos aéreos
la ventaja de los recursos aéreos es que
son rápidos tienen grandes cantidades de
agua y se abastecen más fácil y rápido
que una unidad de intervención de
bomberos
entre los recursos aéreos están los
famosos aviones anfibio
pueden cargarse en el mar y en los
grandes Ríos como aquí en el
vamos a bajar cada vez más y después
vamos a posar el avión encima del agua
es decir reduciremos los gases una vez
que estemos encima del agua vamos a
cargarlo en 12 segundos el avión estará
lleno estos aviones bombarderos de agua
se estacionan en nim en el departamento
de gard en la base de la protección
civil francesa además de los 12 que ya
tiene Francia anunció la compra de
cuatro aviones anfibio adicionales de
los cuales dos Fueron financiados por la
Unión Europea pero será necesario tener
paciencia
estos aviones de 35 millones de euros
cada uno ya no se fabrican
El fabricante de estos aviones anunció
el año pasado que volvería a lanzar su
cadena de producción mientras todo se
pone en marcha anunciaron un calendario
hipotético no sabríamos decirlo con
exactitud pero a partir de 2027
empezarían a entregarse los aviones que
se han pedido a nivel europeo la
protección contra los incendios no solo
consiste en Apagar las llamas sino
también en proteger a la población eso
implica a veces hacer evacuaciones
gigantescas como ocurrió en 2017 en la
comuna de bohm le mimosa en bar para el
conteo hagan una fila por favor ahí hay
intentar salir de las zonas de los
incendios antes de la llegada de los
equipos de rescate a veces puede ser
peligroso nos explican la razón en esta
zona empresarial a las orillas del
Bosque en eón hobbons la idea es ponerse
a salvo en el edificio y sobre todo no
subirse a un auto porque al salir del
edificio uno está bajo la vegetación en
ese momento no estará dentro del auto
ahí bloqueado en la calzada sin poder
salir es cuando se corren riesgos hay
ejemplos de víctimas durante el incendio
de Portugal en 2017 hubo varias decenas
de personas que murieron dentro de sus
vehículos en la carretera
Sebastián la hay era bombero y colgó su
uniforme para convertirse en
investigador especializado en incendios
extremos
su empresa asesora construcciones
ubicadas en zonas de riesgo
la clave consejos personalizados para
que la vivienda sea más resistente a las
llamas
idealmente habría que quitar las cunetas
de PVC es un lugar donde se puede
acumular las hojas también hay algunas
cosas de madera incluso de plástico muy
cerca de la casa que también habría que
quitar o reemplazar por materiales no
combustibles
sensibilizar a la población es
fundamental la ley antiincendios
aprobada en mayo por la asamblea
nacional tiene el mismo objetivo
si no se desbroza y llega un incendio
hasta la casa y no se tienen los
recursos necesarios el seguro no cubrirá
los daños y lo segundo es que las
labores de desbroce deben ser hechas por
empresas autorizadas por personas que
saben hacerlo aumento de las multas por
incumplir el desbrozo obligatorio
prohibición de fumar cerca de zonas
forestales y bosques
Francia ha reforzado las sanciones el
objetivo reducir los incendios causados
por particulares y evitar una temporada
caótica como la del año pasado
[Música]